so we have a question here from the 2015
ap calculus a b test and it says
consider the curve given by the equation
y to the third minus xy is equal to two
it can be shown that the first
derivative of y with respect to x is
equal to that so they
solved that for us
and then part c of it i skipped parts a
and b for the sake of this video
evaluate the second derivative of y with
respect to x at the point on the curve
where x equals negative 1 and y is equal
to 1. so pause this video and see if you
can do that
all right now let's do it together and
so let me just first write down the
first derivative
so d y derivative of y with respect to x
is equal to
y
over
3 y squared minus x
well if we're concerning ourselves with
the second derivative well then we want
to take the derivative with respect to x
of both sides of this so let's just do
that
do the derivative operator
on
both sides right over here
now on the left hand side we of course
are going to get the second derivative
of y
with respect to x but what do we get on
the right hand side and there's multiple
ways to approach this but for something
like this the quotient rule probably is
the best way to tackle it i sometimes
complain about the quotient rule saying
hey it's just a variation of the product
rule but it's actually quite useful in
something like this we just have to
remind ourselves that this is going to
be equal to the derivative of the
numerator with respect to x and so
that's just going to be
derivative of y
with respect to x times the denominator
y squared minus x
minus the numerator
y
times the derivative of the denominator
with respect to x well what's the
derivative of this denominator with
respect to x
well the derivative of 3y squared with
respect to x that's going to be the
derivative of 3y squared with respect to
y which is just going to be 6y
i'm just using the power rule there
times the derivative of y with respect
to x all i did just now is i took the
derivative of that with respect to x
which is the derivative of that with
respect to y
times the derivative of y with respect
to x come straight out of the chain rule
minus the derivative of this with
respect to x which is just going to be
equal to 1.
all of that over remember we're in the
middle of the quotient rule right over
here all of that over
the denominator squared all of that over
3 y squared minus x squared
now lucky for us they want us to
evaluate this at a point as opposed to
have to do a bunch of algebraic
simplification here so we can say
when
let me do it over here so when i'll do
right here
when
x is equal to negative 1
and
y
is equal to 1 well first of all what's
the what's d y d x going to be the
derivative of y with respect to x let me
scroll down a little bit so we have a
little bit more space
the derivative of y with respect to x is
going to be equal to
over 3 times 1 squared which is just 3
minus negative 1. so that's just going
to be plus 1 it's going to be equal to 1
4.
and so this whole expression over here
so i can write the second derivative of
y with respect to x is going to be equal
to well we know that that's going to be
equal to one-fourth
one-fourth
times
three times one squared which is just
three
minus negative one so plus one
minus
one so i'll just leave that minus out
there
times six times one
times one fourth let me just write it
out six
six
times one
times one fourth 4
minus 1
all of that over
let's see this is going to be 3 times y
squared y is 1. so this is going to be 3
minus negative 1. so plus 1
squared now what is this going to be and
this is just simplifying something here
1 4 times 4 that's going to simplify to
1. and let's see this is going to be one
and a half
minus 1 so that's going to be one-half
and then we're going to have all of that
over 16. and so this is going to be
equal to we'll get a mini drum roll here
this is going to be equal to one minus
one-half which is equal to one half
over sixteen which is the same thing as
one over thirty two
and we are done